people the world over traveled to venice
italy to see the famous city's
incredible sights that's why the rarest
sight of all
maybe a venice void of tourists the
pandemic has created that unexpected
situation and right now one industry is
making good use of it
chris livesay is in venice to tell us
all about it
can you believe it you've got an empty
doge's palace in here in saint mark's
square
there's not a tourist in sight now
that's a tragedy for the venetian
economy but if you're making a movie
well then it's an irresistible
opportunity
[Music]
matilda de angelis may be a breakout
star
but today it's this location that's
stealing the show
with postcard perfection venice has long
been a mecca for movies
from 1950s classics
to indiana jones and the last crusade
and who could forget james bond's
tricked-out gondola
in moonbreaker
filming here normally means contending
with tens of thousands of tourists
but today cut to covid it doesn't take
steven spielberg to notice the potential
check this out the tourists leave the
filmmakers show up this is just
one of more than 200 films commercials
and other productions taking place
since the start of the pandemic cove it
aside
what to do about flooding the lagoon
city is routinely hit by severe high
tides a massive disruption to movie
making
but last year a new flood prevention
system began holding back the sea
and now filmmakers no longer need to
panic
now their movies are saving the economy
after kovit devoured
up to 90 percent of local revenue says
simone venturini the councilman who
oversees film
tom cruise who just wrapped his latest
mission impossible here
is among the hollywood royalty bringing
their dollars to venetian businesses
like the luxurious danielle hotel says
its director generico esposito
what would your hotel look like if they
weren't shooting anything right now
probably we like others hotels
we would be closed completely because i
have to say
the most of the guests that we have in
this time
are connected to those productions
productions including
across the river and into the trees
based on the ernest hemingway novel set
during world war
ii it stars liev schreiber
and of course deangelis today she's
stunned to see venice so empty
you're italian what's venice normally
like
uh it's uh it's crazy super super
crowded
it was hard to walk it's kind of sad
but also nice and it's uh
hopefully once in a lifetime to see
venice like this
it's it's magic and sad
with covid's stalling productions in
hollywood venice couldn't be
more attractive says producer rob
mcclain
one more time i think it's easier to get
something done here right now
they've been very supportive of the
filmmaking process and allowed us to
work
throughout this whole period which has
been great we've been fine we're
living in a bubble here a bubble he says
that conveniently resembles
a movie set now more than ever
another thing that makes it easy to film
here the price tag the producer of the
hemingway movie told us that the city
was so happy to have them here
during the pandemic that it let them
film at many of these historic locations
for free for cbs this morning saturday
chris lives say
venice that's exactly what jeff and i
want to know
well they got to make some money on it
yeah make up for the tourist dollars
that they're losing and i
told chris i said sign me up for when
they open up italy and let americans
back in i'm right there